students not unlike the characters in
2003's old school have always found a
way to cut corners when it comes to
tackling homework and exams but now new
technology and artificial intelligence
are making it even easier for students
to cheat a recent story on wired.com
shed some light on how this tech has
become the new CliffsNotes for students
across the nation here with more is CBS
News contributor and wired
editor-in-chief Nicholas Thompson Nick
good morning morning I think how
widespread is this I think it's pretty
widespread
and I think it's only to become more
widespread the tools that students have
available are getting more and more
intelligent more and more accessible and
the teachers don't know about them all
you mentioned the tools what are some of
these online well the tool that we wrote
about in Wired and on this part of the
site called back channel is called
Wolfram Alpha and it's a search engine
so it's kind of like Google but it's a
search engine that actually gives you
the full answer and it's really good at
math so you can put in an algebra
problem you can say you know 3x plus x
squared equals 17 and it will not only
give you an answer it will show you the
steps on how to solve it which you can
imagine as an incredibly useful teaching
tool for a student who is at home we
can't find the answer is figuring out
and you can also think of it as a great
tool for cheating
yeah because well my math teacher always
used to say when you put the problem I
say show your work right which was he
wanted to see how you got to the problem
but he also wanted to see that you
figured out how to do the problem and
didn't just take the answer from
somebody else right so that's the first
step we get calculators or a calculator
feel really good they can solve problems
and the teachers say show your work so
you know that it's not just some
calculator and now Wolfram Alpha goes so
many steps beyond that in so many ways
how do they tell though if it's coming
from this one that you're talking about
versus a student just figuring out on
his or her own you can't that's why it's
hard right so a teacher could say so one
of the things that was written about a
necessity was a teacher who given out it
was a I guess a calculus homework
assignment right and she'd mistakenly
put on problems from the wrong place
that were way too hard that would be on
the students capability the papers came
in and said the problem stats came in
and wait how'd they solved that
something is amiss and so what a teacher
can do is they can go into Wolfram Alpha
type in the problem see the steps that
Wolfram Alpha came up to solve it and
then say oh wait the student completely
matches it so
that's cheating maybe that's a problem
the teacher could also say to the
student hey let's sit down and let's
talk right
maybe classes are in the future gonna
become a little more like Oxford where
you actually just you know talk to the
students and then you can figure out
what they're doing but you don't want to
lose sight of the fact that these tools
are kind of amazing and kind of helpful
and really important for life in the
future right in the future you're not
gonna solve calculus problems in your
head you're gonna use your computer's so
I'm thinking math teachers are gonna
hate my saying it but if we have a
computer that can do it why do I need to
know how to do it on my own and okay so
the guy who made WolframAlpha bad is
what he says he says look the problems
were solving are low-level math problems
you shouldn't be teaching these just
like we shouldn't be teaching you six
times five six times you don't really
need to know or maybe like twenty six
times twenty-five you don't really need
to know twenty-six times twenty-five
immediately because you can do it on any
of your devices including my phone so
you shouldn't spend a lot of time
learning how to do that quickly and
maybe the set of math problems that we
shouldn't be spending our time studying
it's just getting more and more complex
well you're gonna get some mail from men
all right I just wanted to say all right
so if you're a math teacher if your
school how do you how do you deal with
this so I think the way to deal with it
is to recognize that computers are
becoming more and more like humans
artificial intelligence is making the
machines more like people and you need
to really think ahead you need to think
okay in the future these are the tools
they're gonna be available to these
students when they go out in the world
so what are the skills they're gonna
need to learn they're gonna need to
learn some kind of critical thinking
they're gonna need to learn how to work
with the machines they're gonna need to
learn how to type the right things into
the machines and to set your curriculum
not based on the way the world was
thirty years ago or the way the world
even is now but set your curriculum
based on what the world will be like and
that's how the students will benefit the
most which they have this day I'll tell
them not to cheat because that's
important to morally I was gonna say but
I also wish they had this stuff when I
was yeah I have a calculator until I
could do the problem I thanks so much
for being with us thank youing